okay [ __ ] japanese banks man i
i'm about to go [ __ ] mad like okay
so oh god he broke the [ __ ] i broke the
table he's so mad
i have so much salt towards
honest foreign japanese banks do you
want to preface before we get into this
we do love living in japan very kind
country we do
very great and we are british and we
complain about everything about
everything in the uk
i'm an innocent bystander in this case
oh [ __ ] like you don't complain
about the pancakes we complain about
everywhere we live
um and especially if something like is
inefficient
to to a brit you know we will happily
wait in line but if
if that meeting takes any seconds longer
than it needs to we are we are going to
complain the [ __ ] about that
so so japanese banks we have to [ __ ]
since our visa only lasts six months uh
we have to
we have to go to the bank every time to
tell them not to cancel our card
right and the thing about japanese banks
is that you can do
[ __ ] nothing on the phone right
so just just so they don't cancel our
card every time our visa runs out every
time we renew our visa we have to go
there
in person and not just any branch of our
bank we have to go to
the branch that you started we have to
go to that specific branch which if you
don't live anywhere near the branch you
open your bank account you're pretty
much [ __ ] yeah they didn't give me a
warning they didn't tell you yeah yeah
so you could be like stranded in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere in japan and
not be able to get any money out yeah
because they've blocked they've canceled
your card and not told you yeah and
another thing
is i needed to go there for like uh i
needed
a bank statement right you you think for
a bank statement that's a
pretty normal that's a pretty normal
document you can
obtain from a bank correct so i go to
the
i go to the bank and i ask for a bank
statement and they have like [ __ ]
70 million different kinds of bank
statements and i'm just like
what's how hard is it tommy money go in
money go out money and money go out
what what is the document where you can
see money go in
money go out transactions you spend
money here
i just need that document and they're
like okay
maybe we can do that maybe maybe maybe
let's let's see they go they go they go
away i'm gonna talk to the manager yeah
literally literally go away they talk to
the manager they give me like two forms
to fill out and go
and go um so are you okay getting this
in three weeks
um i'm like is there any faster way to
get this documented like
no if you if you want this document
because you didn't sign up for it before
you have to wait three weeks and we'll
send it to you now do you want this
document monthly or do you want us to
like just hold it and then i'm like no
now from now on give me this monthly
because there is no other way to obtain
a statement if unless you just go to the
bank
and ask for it and you have to ask for
this option when you sign up for a bank
account or when you
when you've realized that you need a
bank statement for whatever you know
what is the point of like the 900
printers that they have like what are
you using these printers for
and so and so i'm waiting for this
document
for like for like you know because i i
needed to file some stuff i needed a
bank statement
took five weeks for it to get sent i
didn't realize when i said three weeks
they meant
three like three minimum three weeks
minimum
yeah basically uh japanese banks i don't
know if we've just been really blessed
with uk banks
but in the uk the apps work amazingly
apps work amazingly you can just
transfer money on an app it's pretty
it's
pretty secure and i can have my
statements if i i have like
three to four no [ __ ] five years
worth of like bank statements that i can
pdf do whatever i want japan has those
as well like i use a bank currently that
has a great [ __ ] app and i can do
transactions all on my phone the problem
is
they're not the major banks all of the
major banks are like
you have to go in in person bring your
[ __ ] stamp
and sign like 17 pieces of paper we'll
send you something in two years
yeah because i've wanted to transfer
money back to my uk account for like
since
since i moved here um i just don't i'm
just dreading the ordeal i have to go
through just
just to just so i can move money from
one place it's like a whole day event
it is it [ __ ] well it should be five
minutes long
like every every time i go to the bank i
lose at least an hour or two
of my life yeah it's unfortunate that
like things that should take 10 minutes
or 15 minutes tops are always like four
hours in japan i think that's where the
frustration comes from where it's like
you've put middlemen and checks in
places where there didn't need to be
yeah any you know anything it's like why
do you have to ask your manager if
everything's dude there's a bank
statement
everything anything you do they will
always ask the manager it's like
do any of your employees have the
ability to do anything on their own
are your employees like trained at all
like just just make a [ __ ] decision
for yourself
yeah jesus what are you employed for
yeah i mean like by the time i got the
statement the statement was like already
out of the date
because it was a month old statement
right so
i i had branches i had to [ __ ] i i i
like [ __ ]
begged um because because i was filling
out tax stuff and i was i was [ __ ]
begging my account to be like
please let this be like please please
let this be usable because i don't want
to [ __ ] do this again i don't want to
go through this ordeal again i want to
wait five weeks ago
i think the most frustrating part about
it is that when you're like please help
me with this thing they make you seem
like you're the weird one for like
wanting to like
make stuff go quicker or do things
simpler they're always like why would
you want to do that
yeah this is the way we do it yeah this
is this is the exact this is this is the
way that where it's a hundred percent
success rate so it's like why else would
you make it
any other way well i remember because i
think i think dergan uh
did a video about the japanese banks as
well and he mentioned something else one
time where he was like sometimes you
just have to tell them like no
like yeah just tell them no that's not
gonna work
and then maybe be like you have to do
this or help me do this
and the manager might be like okay but
it's sad isn't it that
sometimes you have to put your foot down
to get anything done here yeah
it's just terrible it's just so sad it's
that you have to like pull tooth and
nail to get the best service
that they offer right yeah which is why
i hate
sometimes i feel bad when i uh ask
japanese people to help me with it
because if i'm like can you ask them to
do this like no no they don't they don't
do that here
it's like if you're a foreigner friend
they'll at least ask they'll be like hey
can we do this but if i'm asking a
japanese friend to help me
like who's 100 japanese you know right
that you know is fluent in english
somewhat
hey can you ask them this they'll be
they won't even ask because they'll be
like no no
you can't ask them that yeah i mean look
at your desk just ask
i try you know
because they don't want to like
embarrass themselves they don't want to
ask questions that they feel
they already know the answer to because
they feel like that that's like
humiliating at times
uh whereas i think i always should of
the mindset of there's no harm in asking